manuel carot orbes bienvenido una vez
más a radio canadá internacional usted
está preparando una nueva propuesta
teatral que es la violación de lucrecia
cuéntenos por favor de qué se trata
bueno pues muy buenos días gracias por
invitarme a otra vez aquí en la radio
canal internacional
pues sí mira este es un tercer proyecto
el último fue el tiempo de ser y está la
violación de lucrecia forma parte luís
de una iniciativa que he tenido yo de
fomentar y dar a conocer el teatro en
canadá realizado en lengua española
entonces este texto yo ya hace tiempo lo
conocía era una historia muy interesante
que me llama siempre me llamaba mucho la
atención y ha coincidido de que es un
solo es una sola actriz
y dadas las circunstancias las
dificultades que ahora tenemos con esta
pandemia pensé que era el momento idóneo
y oportuno pues hacer este tercer
montaje con este texto que me interesa
tanto y con una actriz porque ya se
facilitan las cosas los ensayos los
temas de producción también y también
los temas de gira o sea de más
posibilidades teniendo una actriz de
poderlo mover aquí en canadá cuando sea
posible y también fuera de canadá porque
la idea es poder llevar el texto pues a
latinoamérica a españa porque merece la
pena y estoy trabajando con la actriz se
excelente de mí y saudí travel es una
actriz aquí de quebec que con la que ya
está es la tercera oportunidad que tengo
de trabajar y es muy buena y estoy muy
contento de poder estar realizando este
trabajo con ella ahora la difusión de la
cultura
hispana y la preservación de las
costumbres la difusión del arte
latinoamericano han sido siempre una
preocupación suya han estado presentes
en todas sus obras porque entonces
recurrir a un autor angloparlante para
esta apuesta que fue lo que le atrajo de
esta obra en particular estamos hablando
de william shakespeare sino sí
exactamente lo que atrajo de esta obra
en particular pues mira el primero que
yo he sido siempre un enamorado de
chester
y en segundo lugar porque la historia
que cuenta me llamó siempre me pareció
muy interesante y muy vigente en ese
sentido y shakespeare ha tenido ha sido
muy visionario porque la historia que
cuenta la violación de lucrecia pues es
muy contemporánea en el sentido que
evoca de alguna manera cosas que están
pasando ahora con frecuencia en la
cotidianidad de aquí hay muchas partes
del mundo como son las violaciones la
violencia de género
y porque la obra trata de una violación
en toda regla mira mucho la atención el
tema y también mucho mucho el la belleza
del texto es un texto de verdad es un
texto narrativo al que yo le he tenido
que hacer una adaptación para llevarla
al teatro pero el texto es muy bonito y
entre esas dos cosas de clichés es un
texto muy lindo hay shakespeare uno de
sus pocos poemas narrativos la historia
que me llama una atención y la
oportunidad de poderlo hacer con esta
actriz con esa estrella por eso este
motivo si es que pensar de bueno de
speedy y ponerla en escena este año y
además de la idea central de la obra que
es el tema este de la violación se
encadena con temáticas que han sido
siempre de su interés como el tema de la
mujer la opresión la injusticia cetera
no es cierto si mira en eso sí es verdad
que yo he tenido siempre este tipo de
inquietudes y casi siempre las obras que
he montado sobre todo las dos últimas es
aquí en canadá tienen que ver con una
cosa que siempre louis
me ha inquietado y me ha cuestionado
mucho es el tema de la hipocresía la
falsa moral los prejuicios yo pienso que
son cosas que están tan tan claras en
nuestra sociedad actual que son a mi
entender la consecuencia de cantidad de
problemas que en la actualidad tenemos
todo el abuso del poder por ejemplo es
una cosa que en los textos de
shakespeare imagínate de shakespeare es
una cosa que le ha tocado en sus obras y
el abuso del poder una cosa tan
contemporánea que la vivimos todos los
días
igual que ya te digo son temas muy muy
muy contemporáneos la relación de género
vamos a estar bien del día pasa en
muchos países también un tema importante
que me llama mucho la atención es la la
cosificación de la mujer
en occidente pues más o menos digamos
que las mujeres tienen los mismos
derechos no en todas partes pero la
cosificación de la mujer de alguna
manera está implícita en la obra de
chester en este montaje y eso existe en
muchas culturas actualmente o sea la
mujer tratada como un objeto como una
cosa entonces si son temas
lo que me interesan mucho y que en las
obras de teatro que yo casi siempre he
montado pues he intentado que estén
porque pienso que vale la pena el teatro
también nos tiene que servir para
hacernos reflexionar sobre estas copas
de estas pero en estas cosas
y estos son problemas grandes que
actualmente vivimos que no podemos negar
que existen bueno hay instancia
referencia a la pandemia esta pandemia
de coronavirus en la que estamos todos
inmersos como es producir preparar una
obra de teatro en este contexto en plena
pandemia
te cuento es es complicado obviamente
este virus nos ha condicionado a toda la
vida y también la forma de trabajar en
todos los ámbitos obviamente en el
ámbito teatral pues hemos tenido que
empezar que adaptarnos yo por ejemplo he
estado preparando la obra porque hay un
trabajo previo de mesa de análisis de
texto bueno cantidad de cosas digamos
que es un trabajo y no puede ser
tranquilo de casa y luego el tema de los
ensayos yo estoy sorprendido porque al
comienzo
yo era un poco renuente y no estaba muy
convencido de que el tipo de ensayo
virtual podía dar algún tipo de fruto
positivo y es exactamente lo que hemos
estado haciendo obviamente facilita
mucho que sea una sola actriz entonces
ella lo que ha hecho denis lo que ha
hecho es que en su casa pues ha
condicionado un espacio en el cual poder
ensayar y yo aquí en mi casa pues la
estoy dirigiendo pero la sorpresa que me
ha llevado bastante grande es que
estamos sacando el trabajo adelante
estamos ensayando casi casi igual como
si estuviéramos fuera presencial y para
hacer una adaptación que hemos tenido
que hacer que nuestro trabajo yo pienso
que yo lo veo positivo porque el trabajo
está saliendo adelante y esperamos estar
en esas y ensayando de forma habitual
hasta que ya podamos
pasar a los ensayos ya reales donde el
actor yo esté al frente y yo pueda
admirar lo en fin si se echa mucho de
menos
el ensayo presencial con el actor porque
ahí hay una una comunión una conexión
muy especial y mía como director con el
actor y el actor conmigo si se echa de
menos eso pero no nos queda más remedio
que sacar adelante este tipo de
proyectos a través de estos ensayos
virtuales como los estamos siendo
nosotros otra faceta de la actividad
artística presencial que es valga la
redundancia la presencia de público al
que también supongo que se extraña
muchísimo muchísimo ya por la pandemia
pues ha habido un boom tremendo de toda
de obras de teatro de streaming en todas
partes cursos de teatro y sobre todo el
tema de teatro streaming
ha sido una oportunidad para muchas
compañías muchos profesionales del
teatro una válvula de escape primero
para dar a conocer sus trabajos segundo
también para una oportunidad de poder
conseguir algún dinero porque el claro
los teatros cerrados la gente no va y
entonces sí sé que muchas compañías de
teatro en todas partes del mundo mucho y
latinoamérica han tenido que apelar pues
a esto de de la emisión en estima de sus
obras de teatro y yo pienso que yo lo
veo bien dentro del contexto en la
pandemia obviamente yo lo entiendo pero
sí para mí el teatro esencialmente es
ese esa comunión que hay entre el
público y los actores que eso es que
para mí el teatro es eso
esto es una adaptación que hemos tenido
que hacer que no hay por qué decirte es
horrorosa hay que adaptarse a las
circunstancias pero pero si se echa
mucho de menos contacto con el público
real bastante muchísimo por lo que me
dice si la situación actual se
extendiese esperemos que no pero es una
posibilidad por lo que usted me dice la
realización de esta obra
en línea en streaming como se dice no es
una opción
mira todo depende todo depende sabes que
esta pandemia con esta pandemia tampoco
se puede hacer mucho no los panditas en
muchos planes seguros a largo plazo pues
porque uno sabe mañana qué va a pasar
mañana un gran cierto si esto sé si
tomamos se vacuna o o si llegó por el
contrario todo mundo se contagia mente
entonces nosotros de momento estamos
trabajando ya tengo estamos trabajando
de forma virtual y la idea nuestra en
principio
ya habló del contexto aquí canadiense
ver cómo fue cómo evolucionan las cosas
y ver si laura la podemos estrenar en
verano y si no se puede pues habrá que
plantearse otras alternativas como
grabarla sería una grabación para
poderla hacer su lanzamiento en
streaming pues para el público puede esa
opción es como un plan b digamos así yo
soy optimista yo espero que al menos
para alrededor de junio al menos ya no
sé si es mucho pedir que la gente esté
volviendo en el teatro
y que yo pueda previamente poder estar
haciendo los ensayos con denise la
actriz ya presenciales pero bueno ya
sabe viste con esta pandemia no uno no
puede hacer planes así a largo plazo no
sabemos pero sigue la idea es esa de
todas maneras nos sumamos a ese
optimismo y esperamos efectivamente que
a mitad de año el panorama esté un poco
más claro manuel en una entrevista
anterior hace un par de años habíamos
tratado nuevamente algo que comenzamos a
hablar al principio de la entrevista de
su interés por promover el espectáculo
en nuestra lengua aquí en canadá estos
dos años ha avanzado es a ese objetivo
bastante bastante y lo hemos visto sobre
todo por la asistencia de público a los
montajes anteriores para exponer un
ejemplo para el estreno de tiempo tiempo
de ser que fue la obra que tenemos en el
2019 en ottawa hicimos una corta
temporada fue lleno total
los dos días fue una temporada corta de
todas maneras pero lleno total y un
público que se quedó sin poder asistir a
la obra
también fue que hubo una promoción
grande se ha dado a conocer y es que
luis aquí en canadá hay un público
creciente latinoamericano muy grande que
está ávido de actividades culturales ya
no solamente teatro pero sí actividades
culturales en español donde ellos puedan
ver tener un entretenimiento recreación
pues
en español también una cosa importante
que sea que yo he notado en estos años
estado acá y específicamente respecto a
la asistencia del público a los montajes
que hemos realizado porque haces el
primero fue la farsa del catalán que hay
muchos canadienses que que están muy
interesados en el idioma español de
hecho hay muchos que lo están
aprendiendo y por y por añadidura pues
estas personas están muy interesadas en
todo lo que es la cultura hispánica y
latinoamericana entonces les gusta el
teatro y en los últimos montajes que
hemos hecho como te digo
hemos tenido lleno total o sea los tres
días que hizo que se hizo el papel a los
dos días que se hizo tiempo de ser lleno
total o sea lleno total y eso se
agradece mucho es de donde te digo que
si la gente aquí en canadá está ávida de
ver teatro español es muy saludable y
eso es muy bueno poderlo ver aquí en
canadá en esta ocasión también habíamos
hablado de su actividad docente a través
de la compañía de teatro la pandilla
como el saime pues mira yo cuando venía
cada canal
tuve la oportunidad de de vincularme con
la pandilla que es la compañía de teatro
de la universidad nacional autónoma de
méxico ellos tienen un proyecto de
tienen un área de teatro donde cada año
vienen viene un becario de méxico pues
hacer una práctica teatral
yo me vinculé con ellos principalmente
como colaborador desde que el ine acá
empecé col a colaborar con algunos
aspectos de la formación de los actores
dándoles talleres de bobos de talleres
de interpretación y ha sido inicialmente
como mi vínculo con esta entidad y luego
a partir de los dos últimos montajes ya
han sido montajes totalmente
independientes ya sin nada que ver con
este grupo de teatro la pandilla pero sí
han sido actores que de alguna manera
han sido actores que llevan tiempo
en esta entidad de formándose como
actores y pero ya te digo los dos mismos
montajes montaje es tiempo de ser y este
la violación de lucrecia en concreto si
sonia en proyectos totalmente
independientes manuel caro autores
esperamos que la situación mejore a
corto plazo y que la violación de
lucrecia entonces pueda dentro de muy
poco fijar fecha de estreno y
qué radio canadá internacional sea parte
de esa novedad de una vez más pues
muchas gracias y quisiera hacer un
inciso la actriz con la que estoy
trabajando
denis av de travel es es muy buena
actriz yo también una de las razones por
las cuales quise trabajar este texto fue
porque desde un comienzo quería trabajar
con ella porque es muy buena un talento
y una sociedad muy especiales y iba a
ser un placer para todo el público podrá
ver a ella trabajando haciendo los tres
personajes que hace en este espectáculo
que es un espectáculo único personal y
yo estoy seguro que me ha gustado mucho
este trabajo muchas gracias por tu
entrevista a correo internacional una
vez más y hasta la próxima
muchas gracias a ti